summer is really the hardest time of the
year for me living out here because you
can't really live off the country as
easily as you can the rest of the year
and the winter it can be a lot easier
you can shoot five caribou in one day
when I'm all set for five months at this
time of year there's no caribou around
there's no trapping this summer there's
no big-game hunting in the summer and
even if it were I could never process
that much meat fast enough before
maggots had eaten it up there are things
that you can get out here for food like
fish is one but it's a lot more
labor-intensive you can spend as much
energy and half a dozen fish on here as
you can spend getting one caribou those
half a dozen fish be gone in two days
and that caribou will last a month I
only want to catch a few fish at a time
in order to just eat fresh I don't want
to get into drying fish or trying to
preserve them in the summer time it's a
lot harder to preserve food out here so
you're out there at least every couple
days looking for something to eat I'm
running low on food and I haven't eaten
yet today so I'm gonna go out looking
for some grayling and a creek that flows
out of the lake here it's close to camp
so I'm looking for something to eat this
time of year that's one of the first
places I'll go
the mosquitoes make everything more
difficult just about every job you do
anything you want to do with your hands
you can't wear gloves mosquitoes all
over you got about 15 mosquitoes one
SWAT you gotta urinate got mosquitoes
biting you I don't like to use insect
repellent I don't like putting that
chemical on me every day but you can
cover up but it's hot you don't want to
be wearing long sleeves today if it
wasn't for these mosquitoes I'd be
running around naked it's all part of
nature got to live with it but it's no
fun